oh my gosh we have them Robert how are
you okay Patrick how are you doing I am
doing good first of all happy birthday
to you I know it's been a week but happy
birthday to you it's been two weeks well
thank you very much I appreciate that
was very nice of you yes yes you know
you're one of my favorite guys too to go
out with to eat with to argue it to
debate way to speak with and to do a lot
of different things to disagree with you
I'm just a nice guy I just sit there and
I say let's grab some Rafi's come on you
just want to correct me all the damn
time and you know I'm trying to get
smarter so one of these days
explain to me one thing Patrick how is
it that you have 3.6 million followers
on Instagram and I barely have a hundred
thousand you're not a social media guy
you're a in your does that mean you're
36 times better than I am there's no way
in the world I mean when if it comes to
writing I may be one millionth of the
level of a writer that you are if it
comes down to creating content maybe I
maybe got an upper hand on the content
side but not when it comes up to writing
so how's life how you feeling I'm
feeling okay you know I'm better than
when you saw me boys that when you when
you saw me last
I was pretty pretty it was pretty bad
state I was not I was like in a
wheelchair and I was still very much
under the effects I'm much better
but I thought I'd be a lot further along
than I am right now in other words I
don't think I'm ready to start to try
out for the Lakers yet not yet no a
couple more years maybe lead are you
ready for the d-league or not yet I'll
be ready for like the Wiley I think you
I think your grandmother could take me
to the rim right now your spirits are up
which is cool I like seen yourself yeah
yeah yes spirits are fairly up yeah so
so your last book laws of human nature
I know writing books it's like having a
baby for you you're a perfectionist one
of the reasons why I don't miss a single
award of a book you write if you've
written any book I've read it
and I'm a big student of your content
how do you feel your book get I know
you're you're the author how do you feel
your book did it's been hugely
successful I mean we're about will be
two years into it in in October and the
sales have exceeded any of my other
books including the 48 laws
Wow and that's that's not to say it'll
have the same impact as the 48 laws
because that that grew over the years
but it's been incredibly successful and
a lot of it is audible it seems like a
lot of people these days are preferring
to refocus on audible as opposed to
getting the actual copy of the book but
I'm not complaining you know we've we
sold well over 350,000 copies so far so
that's not bad not bad at all 350,000
copies at what's the price point of the
book 35 bucks cuz it's not a small book
so 3540 dollar book and well paperback
is less paperback is less a good price
point it's good to hear so for some of
us that are always hoping you're working
we'll greet the greedy ones too greedy
curious who folks who consume your
content are you planning on giving birth
to another book anytime soon or you're
not working on anything
oh I sure AM I'm about I'm about two or
three months pregnant right now
you know metaphorically speaking the
more timeframe so I've been working very
hard on the research for about a year
now and this summer I plan on going
through all my notecards and begin the
writing process so I'm very much
immersed in that right now it's kind of
if that's what keeps my spirits up you
know because I'm not able like most
people I can't go to the gym I can't do
my usual routines but those hours that
I'm working on my book that that's
what's sustaining me right now can you
give us a hint of what the topic is
about or no anything like even a glimpse
of it well it's a slightly more
spiritual book quote-unquote I hate to
use that works it sounds soft and people
go over Robert Greene's getting soft
I don't think so basically it's a book
about what I call the sublime and it's
something I
upon in my last book and the way I
described it is life being a human being
and living in society in a civilized
world it's kind of like a circle a crew
are being a social animal we create kind
of limits and conventions to how we're
supposed to think how we're supposed to
behave how we're supposed to operate in
the world and those kind of conventions
and codes that we operate by the rules
at a certain point they kind of become
oppressive it kind of limits what we
think it limits what we do and I'm
saying to kind of go beyond that circle
to explore beyond your limits in
whatever area in your thoughts and your
actions whatever that is there's an
experience that is incredibly life
enhancing and it expands your creativity
it expands what you can do is generally
therapeutic in life and I call that
experience the sublime where you're
pushing past your own physical and
mental limits I'm going very very very
deep into the book the ultimate limit is
of course death itself and so you know I
had a I had a near brush with death
myself and so being able to overcome
your fear of mortality is the ultimate
way of going beyond that circle is the
ultimate way of expanding your limits if
you lose your fear of death you will
slowly lose all of those other fears
that are plaguing you in life just
something I personally experienced with
my own with my own stroke so it's it's
it's a very important book to me I meant
to write it 14 years ago but then the
50th law intervened and everything kind
of got off track but since my stroke
it's a book that means a lot to me and I
hope it'll be good I think it'll be good
one Patrick Patrick likes it it's a good
book this year micrometer year month you
haven't written a book I don't like
that's the problem
you know like give me one book that I
can't promote I love all your books you
know you I'm you're walking a commercial
you know everywhere I go I try to get
people to reach out I when I got a
haircut my buddy Michael rapattoni I
said Michael you got to read the loss of
human nature says what are you tossing
you guys that's a big book I said
go buy it you'll thank me later and we
had our entire company read the book
every single agent on the company was
required to read your book and write a
paper on it's that powerful of a book
Robert out of curiosity out of all the
books you read which one was the most
emotionally draining to write because it
took the most out of you yeah that's
probably why I had my stroke it took
five years and you know the problem for
me is I don't like I just don't write a
book to make money and I don't write a
book just to please my ego I really
really think deeply about the reader my
whole philosophy is I want to get inside
your brain I want to infiltrate into you
get inside your blood and literally
alter how you look at the world have a
deep impact online and because I'm so
ambitious that way it requires so much
effort in so much work on my part that
it was very very exhausting where are
you going I'm gonna go to my office I'm
trying to grab your books because I want
to show the folks that are on here that
maybe don't recognize your face but once
they see the book they're gonna know
what books it is but go ahead I'm
listening to you said the last one took
five years and it was very exhausting
yeah I was very exhausting because I
really want to get it something true I
want to get it something real I want
people to say yeah he's really
explaining human nature yes he's really
excluded explained power or the process
of mastery so you know I I go all-in
when I write a book it's I'm like Kobe
Bryant I'm God rest his soul
you know I give it everything that I've
got and then some yeah the reason why I
asked that question is because when when
I read your books your books I mean the
way you go into the amount of research
you bring in and how you tie it all
together
like even reading you to get to a point
in its almost like a climax right like
when you're when you're having a you
know some private time with somebody and
you're enjoying yourself and you go to
the right place and climax it's like oh
my gosh that was amazing reading your
books it's like having sex men I don't
know how to say that's like sex when
reading books it's a very strong analogy
use but it just never ever you're the
first you're the first person to put it
in those terms that's very interesting I
don't know what Freud would say but you
know it's very good Thank You Patrick
that means in the last 24 months your
books have had sex with 350,000 people
you are you're you're you're bigger than
will Chamberlain you ought to be proud
of yourself it's like well I did write
the art of seduction you're all good yes
you did I got to this year those are
amazing bookshelves you have yeah just
here at the office but then I got a I
got a bigger one at the Home Office
these are the ones I have here
you haven't been your invite you out
yeah I was hoping to bring you out here
obviously the plan was for you to come
out until an event took place but it's
it's fine I just wanted to kind of show
couple the books that I have here of
your soul so let me ask you a different
question a technically I stand for you
just out of curiosity how are you
feeling about Jenny say hello okay and
then she said hello how are you feeling
about everything that's going on in in
the world today and I'm talking
specifically with coronavirus how are
you feeling about all that stuff with
what's going on well it's a pretty large
question I mean I'm very worried you
know I for instance I had pretty big
portfolio in Wall Street a lot of stocks
and I got out of the stock market which
you know maybe at the time wasn't very
smart because it's it's been going up
but I've lost confidence I'm very
concerned about the overall
ramifications of this pandemic and so I
also feel very I feel I have a lot of
empathy for what a lot of people must be
going through right now you know I I the
life of a writer is pretty much the life
you're already under quarantine you
spend most of your time in your house
working and writing so I haven't had to
adjust very much but I know how
difficult it can be how it can be lonely
I can start climbing the walls how you
can start you know wasting a lot of time
and how the isolation can affair
- this is something that people aren't
talking about as much and something I
study a lot I think that I'm worried
about the long-term psychological
ramifications of this crisis on the
surface people look fairly good like
they're adjusting they're either wearing
their masks or they're doing their
isolation or whatever it is but I think
long term there's gonna be some problems
and some issues and I'm telling people
that you know there's a lot of happy
talk out there you go on the internet
and people are always trying to boost
and say everything is great everything's
fine and I'm trying to say you know you
need to think about what could happen to
you if this kind of levels of fear and
caution get inside your bloodstream and
five or six months down the road or a
year from now when we finally emerge
what are the effects this is going to
have on your psychology the
ramifications it's something I can't say
for sure I'm not I'm not
Nostradamus but I'm very worried about
it I mean there are all sorts of aspects
that concern me but I think it's very
real what what are the worst things that
could happen to us
worse things work work and disco mindset
why psychologically well I remember you
know my parents I'm older than you
obviously and I reparent grew up in the
depression particularly my father he was
born in 1920 and he never got out of
that depression mentality right he was
always he was very worried about ever
spending a lot of money on anything he
was always waiting saving was incredibly
important and those were somewhat
positive values but it made a lot of
people very very skittish particularly
their relationship to money and so I'm
worried about people becoming overly
cautious
like I I make a point in mastery of
saying you need to find a path in life
where you're you're going in a direction
that emotionally connects with you that
you haven't you choose a career that in
some way connects to who you are now it
can't be you obviously have to make
money you have to have a living and it's
very important you need food on the
table and I understand that but it's
really important that you have other
values other things that are important
to you like fulfilling your life's
mission your lives tasks and so I'm
worried that people are gonna get overly
conservative about their career moods
about who they are and about what
they're planning for the future and
they're gonna grab a job you know that's
one of the ramifications that I'm
worried about very interesting yeah
that's very interesting because that
that element you when you said your
father was born in 1920 that's what
happened to his generation
they were just kind of taking the safe
rod and kind of creativity went out yes
very much so I mean they're their era
was like the 1950s right he was in his
30s then it was kind of his peak era
which might be the same now for
Millennials so I'm very worried about
Millennials and that was a very kind of
stagnant period of Conformity etc so
these things they don't just go away
they have a lasting impact on people I
believe yeah don't you think it's the
the thing is that this is a lot
different than the depression because
there is that the part with Great
Depression I was looking at it the other
day with numbers and I wouldn't looked
at FDR you know a lot of times you got
the Republicans and the Democrats
Democrats they love FDR and Republicans
will go typically Reagan I'm talking
alas undred years I'm not talking like
George Washington or whoever else he
going to pass and one of the things
about FDR when you look at him he didn't
do a massive bailout yeah he did minimum
wage to 25 cents but he raised at one
time to 25 cents yeah needed Social
Security but it was only for people
about 62 years old and the benefits
didn't go to that many people it was
only like sixty-four thousand people at
the time so the comparable of that time
versus today back then these guys had
nothing to eat they were trying to just
you know break bread and just have
enough for everybody versus today you
got 41 million people that are
unemployed but you got trillion dollars
of money that's being sent out to a lot
of people said they're not because if it
was like great depression crime would be
very very up how do you process that as
a critical thinker yourself on the
difference between Great Depression and
today well the only thing that FD
did was he he had a lot of work programs
so his main thing was was dealing with
unemployment and he put a lot of people
to work with massive infrastructure
projects building dams he even employed
a lot of writers to write things for for
the New Deal etc so his whole thing was
creating all kinds of jobs through the
public sector which I know is something
most conservatives like yourself
probably don't respect very much but he
was he was very proactive in that sense
but you know you're asking are you
asking me about the bailout now or what
are you asking me that was no because
you said your concern is that your
father was born in 1920 and after the
Great Depression you made the comparison
of the fact that maybe yeah he will go
down and I was making a point to say
economically the level of fear and
frustration and concern in a household
of today is not comparable to 1920s and
a Great Depression because people are
being bailed out so doesn't that kind of
cause the fact that creativity will not
take a hit over the next few years well
I don't think people are being
completely bailed out I mean I think
people are feeling a lot of fear and
they're feeling quite helpless because
we first of all we don't know the
long-term ramifications of it the
bailout program you know the twelve
hundred dollar checks that people got I
don't know how far that's going to carry
them I don't know what else you're
referring to
you know the trillions of dollars didn't
necessarily go to the average person out
there in the American in the public so I
think people are dealing with a massive
amounts of insecurity and uncertainty
and from my study of human nature the
aspect of uncertainty is one of the
worst things that a human can deal with
we like things that are predictable we
like to be able to know what is going to
be happening tomorrow or next month or
next year and as opposed to the Great
Depression which was very clear the
source of it and what we could do about
it
although we could argue about different
programs we're not really certain about
this we really don't know where we're
going to be in one year right we really
don't know where the economy is going to
be and also we're going to
a phase-in in capitalism of what they
call creative destruction which is a
this is generally a positive phenomenon
in capitalism where with progress huge
industries are completely obliterated as
new ones arise but now we're going
through a massive level of destruction
of industries that were there just a
year ago that are gone completely what's
going to happen to the tourist industry
what's going to happen to the whole
entertainment segment people here in
Hollywood there's a massive
restructuring going on about how are you
gonna make a film you can't make a film
with social distancing so these are
things that go far beyond the Great
Depression in the 1930s as far as
affecting the very overall structure of
capitalism and where we're going to be
in a year or two years a lot of things
are being weeded out and completely
destroyed that won't be there in a year
yeah I know you call me a conservative I
mean the label you're more conservative
than I then and and you said I never
work for public Robert I've worked for
the public and you've never worked for
the pie I never said that I never said I
didn't say that you miss quoted me I
understand I was a government employee
for three years of my life do you
realize that I was cleaning kitchens
fixing hummer mechanics I was when you
were in the military that was a
government property for for eight years
yes I was in a military that's best
public right that's not pregnant that's
but I never said you were didn't you
know when you and I talk I'm gonna give
you a hard time because you give me I'm
always expecting it well I've been my
whole life in the private sector so I
have that on you yeah yes you have an
entrepreneur than you I'm not as
die-hard of a conservative Republican
capitalist as you are I'm not at your
level yet I'm not feeling it okay all
right somebody else someone has to good
question you're I think it has a lot to
do with the new book you're working on
and I like the way you you you put it
out there is how does one I mean if you
read the book I think it's either
thinking I think it is thinking or it's
when he talks about the
among the biggest fears people have is
what death and you hear about public
speaking heights all this other stuff
and you hear about death how does one
face and address the fear of dying how
do you how do you even do it because as
we age oh you know I feel like life is
through stages where you age and you
experience some friends dying and you
get into your 40s you worry about your
parents dying and you go into 50 60s you
worry about siblings friends and then
you worry about yourself how does one
you know address the fear of death well
the first thing is you have to confront
reality that's what the sort that's what
all my books are about and the reality
is you could very easily die tomorrow so
you're in your 20s and you're seeing
this vast vista of time in front of you
but it's not true you could catch a
major illness you can have an accent of
course your chances are less than me
who's now 61 I'm sorry to say but I know
sorry so but you could be you know your
the moment you were born your death was
said the sentence of death was upon you
and it could be you can live to 80 you
could live to 90 I hope so
but you could very well die in your 40s
and 50s I have had friends who died in
their 40s it's rather shocking but it
can happen yeah so you're living in an
illusion you're walking around always
think it's other people's never me it's
always other people who are mortal to
other people who are going to die but no
you are going to die it's happening
right now it cells inside of you are in
the process of dying right so confront
that you know I always say death is
there it's facing you it's there and
it's like hunting you and you're turning
your back on it because you're afraid of
it I'm telling you to look at it square
in the eye and deal with it and it's not
for it's not gloomy it doesn't mean
you're gonna go around feeling morbid
thoughts yeah it's actually incredibly
liberating and and what it means is that
first of all you realize that your life
is short you know unless unless you're
Elon Musk or Peter Thiel and you're
trying to do all these things where
you're taking medicine to make you live
to 200 your life is relative
short right so knowing that it's short
may gives you energy gives you a sense
of urgency because you a sense of
desperation I've got to get things done
I've got to be with my children I gotta
help them can become better I have to
get things done I can't just sit there
in waste time it gives you a sense of
urgency it also makes you appreciate
everything moment around everything
going on around you you know I came like
this close to dying myself if honor
hadn't been in the car with me and
hadn't called 9-1-1 right away I
wouldn't be talking to you right now or
I would have had severe brain damage but
now when I look around I see the world
around me it doesn't look the same it
looks wow it's amazing the fact that I'm
just alive so it makes you grateful for
what you have and most people walk
around with a sense of they're not
grateful they don't understand what they
have just to actually be alive so
confronting your mortality will actually
have all these psychological benefits
it'll give you energy
it'll make you appreciate what you have
right now but the question is how do you
do it and you have to think about it
almost like as often as you can
I I meditate every morning and often I
go through a process where I very much
deeply think about what's going to
happen to me how one day I'm gonna be
facing my death and I visualize it and I
try and put myself physically there and
so it becomes something real it becomes
something physical and emotional inside
of me and if you've studied like samurai
warriors you know who face death every
time they picked up their sword for a
fight you know they knew that being able
to to do they would meditate every
single day on the fact that this could
be their last day on earth and it got
rid of all of their fears and it helped
them face this incredibly stressful
world that they lived in so not
confronting your mortality you don't
think of it this way you think of it as
just this kind of overall something
that'll happen to you years from now and
you're kind of avoiding it and maybe you
play a little game where you kind of
think about it but you're not really
thinking about it you don't realize
how that infects you generally how it
makes you afraid of taking risks in life
how it makes you afraid of making a
career change how it makes you afraid of
relationships with people makes you
afraid of your boss it's the one thing
it's a it's the tree all the roots of
your fears come from that one source
your fear of your own mortality that was
that was very very deep Robert right
there Bob Lake I'd Mario Cal if you're
watching this grab your paper and pen
and my iPad if you don't mind I want to
take notes while he's speaking if you
Chi Kyle or Mario one of you guys grab
me an iPad at a paper pen so Robert let
me ask you this do you believe in God do
you believe in a creator um I believe
that there's something larger than
ourselves and I think it's extremely
important to think about that and can
connect to it in some way I was
personally raised Jewish and I didn't
really like organized religion I found
it kind of empty it didn't really appeal
to me there was it was sort of like
there was nothing emotionally connecting
me to this to to God or anything like
that and that's probably my own fault or
my own experience but personally I feel
like spiritual values are extremely
important to me and feeling like there
is some force much much larger than we
are out there and that we're actually
incredibly small is that it's something
I'm going very deeply into my next book
because I think with the end of religion
and I can say that religion is fading
mostly in the world in most parts of the
world except for um you know like the
Middle East that something is missing
that we miss something from it that it
had a credibly important value for us as
human beings and I think it causes a lot
of problems for us when we don't believe
in something larger than ourselves
you euro you to me you're like a
modern-day Plato soccer I said this to
many many times when you and I sit down
and talk and we go through it but I say
that I asked this question from you
because I'm always curious about some
thank you I'm always fierce by
of people like you who are very very
well-read and you're you have your own
strong opinions and that's not coming
from a person that just kind of watched
a couple things on new CNN Fox MSNBC
here's what I believe when you say stuff
you saying based on a lot of different
books you've read what do you think
happens at this point after reading all
this stuff what are your thoughts what
happens when we die what happens when we
die I don't really know I don't have an
answer you know I think it's kind of its
kind of arrogant for me to say I mean
I've been reading a lot of books for my
new book about near-death experiences
and it's very interesting how people
have these experiences that seem to
indicate that there is life after death
right and I know for instance that I
have dreams constantly about my father
who passed away 20 years ago almost as
if he's alive there he's talking to me
but I can't go and say that I have any
sense of certainty but there is life
after death as far as I know we die we
disintegrate and ourselves returning to
the earth and they go somewhere else
into some other life form you know
almost like a karma type thing
I don't really know Patrick and I don't
know if I'll ever know until I'm
actually dead so I don't have an answer
yeah to me the reason why I asked that
is because to me sometimes certain
answers with certainty about things that
we don't know anything about to me is
extremely arrogant I understand I
believe I have faith in maybe this is
what happens or possibly this is what
takes place but sometimes you people
give answers of things like that would
its level of certainty that comes across
as being arrogant I just thought maybe
what direction you would have gone with
that so you know going back to the
conversation about that calm about to
the conversation about death do you
think sometimes sometimes people who you
know are living their lives and they're
just kind of going about their
day-to-day stuff and they don't spend
enough time thinking about hey the fact
that you don't have a lot of time left
on earth they don't end up maxing it out
meaning they don't end up giving
everything they got to see how what kind
of a mark Takai don't leave in the world
the reality is Robert let's just say
you're talking about dying they've got
forbid the day comes when you're dying
you're not really dying in my world
because this stuff is gonna live on you
know what I'm saying and I know that's
gonna live on and people gonna be
talking writing reading debating your
content they're gonna say this guy sucks
he has no idea what he's I disagree
that's what's gonna happen because
there's a lot of people that disagree
with your stuff and there's a lot of
people that love your stuff do you think
a lot of people missed the point of life
by not given everything they have
you know cuz they don't think about the
fact that death could cause a high level
of urgency do you think a lot of people
don't think about it that way yes a lot
of people don't necessarily aren't
really connected to this idea that they
have a task in life that they have it's
a destiny and that when they were born
they were meant to accomplish something
but I believe everybody is missing that
so if you've ever spent a day working
very hard on a project or doing
something in your garden and fixing
something around your house at night you
feel very satisfied you feel like you
did something very productive and you go
to sleep with a kind of a nice feeling I
got something done but it's the same
thing with your life you know if you're
in your 50s and 60s and you've never
really realized your dreams you never
attempted to write that book to start
that business because you were always
afraid and now you're facing death in
your 60s that's a horrible feeling it's
a sense that you wasted your gifts and
it I believe it and I don't mean this in
a Pollyannish way I believe everybody
have some natural talent or gift
something that makes them as an
individual has a unique perspective it
has something very important to
contribute and I don't mean you have to
be Elon Musk or the President of the
United States I mean you can be a great
carpenter you can even be a great
plumber but you're really good at you
take it seriously and it's a craft and
you want to be the best at it and this
is what I call appealing to our higher
nature and our lower nature wants to
just waste time just want sort of simple
easy pleasures but when you give in to
your higher nature you have a sense of
fulfillment and knowing that your tie
is limited knowing that you don't have
4050 years to waste on on on the
internet or you know surfing internet
porn or whatever it is your addiction is
knowing that you only have so much time
left is actually going to energize you
and give you a sense of I've got a life
is a precious thing it only happens once
right as far as I know and to waste it
and to waste your years and to waste
what will give you the most amount of
fulfilment is to me tragic so you know
that's how I answer your question I just
I just want to on behalf of everybody
you just offended a couple hundred
people when you said a waste that we
lost a couple hundred people right now
you made a very offensive a comment
about people that were internet porn it
were very offended there's a big porn
community out there you know it's it's
it's particularly your followers maybe
for some people that is productive time
I don't know I shouldn't say that I
shouldn't generalize you know some
people it's it's spiritual that's how
they get there yes and spiritually but
that was a whole different topic I have
no desire to get into the porn topic
with you um mother what you sounded like
a capitalist for a moment there just so
you know you sound like a capitalist
because you said the connection of
giving your best to do something and you
know you know feeling worthy and all
that stuff that exists in the
capitalistic world because you can leave
your mark so it was very impressive we
did wonder wouldn't you think you think
I'm a cup of Communists or something
what do you think that your communist I
think you are a capitalist but I think
your compassion capitalist I think
you're somebody that I think your
compassion count I don't think you're a
crony capitalist guy I think you're
totally against those games I know I
know where you stand politically I mean
one time you and I went to a Clippers
game one of the best playoff Clippers
games if you remember that that was
because they lost any Clippers that I
hate they lost and it was such a great
game they were ahead by 40 points then
they slowly lost it was
so exciting Thank You Patrick and Bob
that was my birthday yes it was and but
if you don't forget they made the
comeback with hardened on the bench
because you know what hardening the game
that's right that's crazy what happened
that you know what I'm saying is you and
I have had a lot of great conversation
weepin if you remember one time we want
to spend some time with Shaq when there
was the Laker thing going on with that
special event if you remember that I was
really cool James Worthy all those guys
let me ask you how much are you watching
because to me you know one of the
reasons why your your the book you wrote
that's my favorite book of all time you
know it's 33 strategies award that's
number one on my list I know there's
Harley yeah that's my number one that's
my ultimate number one app I've got our
company read that five times in five
different occasions because it's a you
got to read multiple times and I'm all
about number four the book is an
incredible book it explains a lot of
things that I resonate with but how much
you watch with what's going on right now
politically and you know cuz to me it's
all strategy strategy on the right
strategy on the Left strategy with the
mana strategy with marketing who do you
think is strategically playing better
a strategy right now to win to 2020
election just purely not opinion on
belief system more political strategies
what I'm curious about what you'll say
about that well I'm not really totally
impressed with anyone right now to be
honest with you and I do some political
consulting you know it strategy is
extremely important in winning an
election but almost even more important
is timing right so George W Bush became
elected because it came at a certain
moment in time and he was facing Al Gore
whatever and then he faced weekend it's
Barack Obama people were ready for that
kind of change they were sick of W and
the wars and everything and then Trump
was facing Hillary and circumstances had
changed so a lot of it is timing and
circumstances and it's a little bit of
luck involved
so right now you know if you look at it
to me objectively the sir
from stances favor change normally we
change after eight cycles of eight years
but this could be one of those times
where after four years because of the
crisis because of trumps overall
popularity numbers which have never
risen up over a certain amount its
against him the winds are against him if
this hadn't happened if the economy was
still booming I don't know I wouldn't I
wouldn't be saying that but right now it
looks like the circumstances face are
favored by me okay so it's almost okay
for him to be locked in his basement and
dock doing anything because he's kind of
a gaffe machine right every time he
speaks every time he does a public
appearance something incredibly stupid
comes out of his mouth it's good to had
him locked up in the basement
not able to appear and it's fine to have
Trump going out there continually
stepping on his own feet and making a
mess of things but you know you've got
to look longer-term right and so the
problem with the strategies now are so
the weakness for Biden and the Democrats
is what is your program for getting out
of this crisis what is your economic
ideas your plan for where we're going to
be in a year can you lay that out can
you give us a sense of hope exactly
where you stand exactly what you're
going to do maybe he'll do that in the
next few months but I don't have a very
clear sense of that the Republicans is a
complete mess I don't know what it means
anymore to be a Republican does it mean
fiscal conservatives and certainly not
when you're the deficit is gonna be
large you're printing money left right
and center and I think you're a
monetarist I remember correctly yeah so
you know and it
so things that are traditionally what is
it that you stand for what is your
long-term plan and some of the things I
generally think Mitch McConnell is a
very savvy strategist he's actually more
of a great tactician than a strategist
but some of the things he's doing making
me the idea that he's not very keyed
into the incredible losses the
Republicans might face in 2020 in the
Senate you know so I don't think either
of these parties are really crafting a
long-term solid vision for the future
which i think is what people are really
really hungry for if I were their
consultant that's where I would be
putting my time and my money yeah if I
was them I'd hire you in a heartbeat I'm
not being funny I would hire you in a
heartbeat and I would you know bring you
in and tell you until the election is
over with that I want you to be talking
about any of this stuff publicly what is
the number III do consult with some
political figures not in the United
States mostly and the thing is you don't
want anyone to know that I'm actually
consulting for it absolutely if word
gets out that the author of the 48 laws
of power is working for you boy
the proverbial [ __ ] will hit the fan so
it's better that people don't know about
that so if you're interested in me
you've got to keep it on on the Qt here
I like that I like what you just said
right there so I'm if I'm reading like a
different kind of a language I kind of
read into it maybe there's like
something going on there but that's
that's good to know
so I tell you one thing it's very weird
I did have lunch with Bernie Sanders I
know that you're gonna tar me with that
but it was what the girl wasn't by
myself I was with about a dozen other
people it was like a strategy session
here in Los Angeles because at a point
where his numbers were very low and he
was very concerned and that was
interesting you know but um he isn't
somebody that I would vote for but I was
actually kind of impressed with him as a
person he was very funny yeah honestly
if you ask me as a candidate to be able
to rally troops but I can cannot compete
with Sanders not even close
Sanders is a is a rally or like no other
I mean he's uh you know if you remember
Ron Paul on the other side as a
libertarian was trying to do stuffs and
receive is even got a ten times better
energy than Ron call obviously
philosophically they're completely
different but it would have been
interesting to see I think a Bernie
Sanders and a Trump on stage would have
been my god that would be like Mike
Tyson
the best thing about the best thing
about Bernie is is incredible digital
strategy incredible presence on the
Internet and that is biden's by far
greatest weakness and that is something
that Trump is actually and the
Republicans are actually very good at so
I'm very concerned about that absolute
but I agree that debate would have been
awesome do you do you do you count are
you hoping relying on Biden picking
somebody if you have kind of a name
you're thinking and banking on or not
really um I'm thinking he's gonna
probably choose Kamala Harris because I
think with what's going on in the news
particularly now in his most recent
gaffe about you you're not glad you
don't vote for me
yeah and the riots going on right now I
mean who knows where we'll be in a few
months but I think the pressure is for
him to choose a black female veep and I
I've always kind of liked Kamala Harris
she's not perfect but she's tough she's
got that lawyer mentality she's a pit
bull she's great in debate she can be
great in debates she's uneven and I you
know she's got some weaknesses but I
like her as a she's tough you know
whereas I don't think stacy abrams has
anywhere the stature to become president
you know so you have to think of he's
only gonna be in there for one term if
he wins who will be this president that
you're selecting this ryeom's afterwards
so that's a very important my money
right now is on Kamala Harris but we'll
see I'm not Nostradamus and I'm
frequently wrong as you know do you
think there's any chance that Michelle
will agree to be the VP any Michelle
Obama yeah you're the second person that
brought they're not the other person was
Ryan holiday and both of you I think
it's a great idea but I've never heard
anybody in the press or anybody mention
it I don't know why I'm bringing that up
let me tell you why anything that up
okay so let me paint a picture for you
if you and I get hired as a strategist
I'm your assistant you're the main chief
strategist I'm the sidekick they say hey
Robert we'll take you in this Middle
Eastern guy in a patch with David and
you and I are talking
to give these guys a presentation
tomorrow to the Democratic DNC whatever
it is and they're sitting there who
should it be if it's Michelle let me
tell you how many arguments it takes
away for Trump if they go with Kamala
you already know what viral videos
trump's camps gonna make when Kamala
sets stuff about Biden and but it's all
marketing are you kidding me you know
there's there's one comment I mean come
on how many how many things did Lindsey
Graham say about Trump that people eat
that stuff doesn't but that's
essentially you're talking about a VP so
watch this if if he if the shell chooses
to become the VP within two years she's
the president United States she'll be
the first female president in the
history of United States because here's
what would happen let me paint a picture
my candidates gonna be Michelle Obama
Jeff's gonna be like wait a minute who
Michelle Obama yeah oh my gosh that's a
curveball so now if he says are you
comfortable having a president that's 78
years old Biden and he's not even
healthy a lot of voters are gonna be
like actually we're very comfortable
with that because within a couple years
Michelle's gonna be the president are
you kidding me so then two years later
Biden comes out and Biden says look the
doctor said I have to make a real
decision about my health and I don't
think it's fair for somebody like me to
leave the country with not my health not
being the best I appreciate you guys for
voting for me but I'm resigning and
stepping down and Michelle Obama is now
your president he becomes a president in
history books
Michelle becomes the first woman
president in history books it's a pretty
interesting storyline right there now
again I've just kind of I like I want to
see a good fight and I see that
happening well it's a very interesting
idea I like coming out of nowhere let's
you say like a curveball the only
problem that I see in that is we've been
living for four years under a president
who had no government experience right
he the first time in our history we
actually hired as president someone with
no government experience totally a
businessman in the private realm people
if they are tired of Trump they're tired
of the chaos they're tired of the
mismanagement they're tired of the
inexperience itself
Michelle Obama has never run
in her life she's never I don't I mean I
know she was a lawyer if that's correct
right but I don't know what her work
background is and I don't know when her
last bit of employment was she has no
experience in government do we want to
do that go through that all over again I
mean I think she's very smart she's very
capable but if we're talking about the
moment that we're living in I don't know
it's a very interesting choice and I
think it will certainly grabbed a lot of
headlines and make a big splash much
like Sarah Palin did for John McCain but
I don't know if it's gonna carry Biden
across the goal posts or not I mean it's
very interesting I would I think it's a
good idea I'm always in for surprises
and boldness and Biden's weakness is
he's not very bold he needs to show some
cojones here and choose somebody you
know that we didn't expect so I like it
for that aspect of it and she's very
popular and also it's very interesting
but it has weaknesses yeah but okay so
you're talking about a woman that
solstice she made 36 million dollars off
a book last year you're talking about oh
I can't I can't compare with that well
no no I'm she's a people she's a first
lady and it's a complete different story
I'm not even making the comparison I
just thought I had no income Allah so
she's she made 36 million with a book
last year she's got eight years of
experience being the first lady to a man
who was a one-term Senate it's not like
he had a lot of experience and it's it's
to a to a press to a candidate like
Biden who man I don't if you know if he
inspires his own wife I mean I don't
even know who he inspires who's gonna
like who wakes up and says I can't wait
for him to be the president like they
have to really pick a strong VP because
when when I noticed that the face of the
Democratic candidates gonna be him
I was concerned this is why look I don't
know no wait no wait you you're not
totally right there who who was the
candidate that Trump feared the most of
all the Democrats spied he fears him the
most he disappeared on me wearing on my
office and the light turns off every 30
minutes
come on oh there's just a timer we have
in here so you have a clapper
I know it's not a collaborative it
notices when there's a strong connection
between a guest on Instagram life the
lights goes off so it was kind of
feeling the the connection we were
having but go ahead so you were saying I
was afraid of one candidate I'm assuming
you're saying Biden yes he was that was
why they had the whole thing drunk this
afraid of bite definitely we know that
it's been reported over and over do this
why that's why he that's why he did the
whole thing she that's why he yes
because he cut skin to the white
working-class that he thinks is his
bedrock those people in Pennsylvania and
Michigan look Patrick you're ignoring
the fact that Biden won all of these
primaries in states that traditionally
went to Trump he's very popular in
Michigan he's very popular in
Pennsylvania he has roots in
Pennsylvania and Trump was very very he
was much more worried about Biden than
he was about Bernie for instance they
were they were licking their chops that
they could get Bernie a socialist think
of the material they would have for that
okay so I agree Biden is not doesn't
have much charisma but there are plenty
of moments in American history where we
have elected presidents who were very
low on the charisma scale I don't think
w had a hell of a lot of charisma
I don't think Dwight Eisenhower I mean
he had a great history but he was very
kind of a rather dull personally Dwight
Eisenhower how much was TV playing a
role I mean it said well that's true
different ball games so I'm talking to
me Jimmy Carter Jimmy Carter was a
pretty dull president and George the
first Bush he had very little charisma
sometimes sometimes being a bit dull
will play well if you're coming after
someone who had lots of drama and lots
of chaos I mean let me let me ask you
this question who has more charisma
Hillary Clinton or Joe Biden Hillary who
is scarier Hillary Clinton or Joe Biden
Hillary is it even in the same league
scarier in what sense just on stage
presence like Hillary is intimidating
she's got a certain level of swagger
she's very confident you
that people don't like that in a woman
and that played against her in 2016 you
know yeah I don't know I guess all I'm
saying look you have to know for me
remember the days where you go to fight
and Tyson with knockout players in eight
seconds and you spend $6,000 for a fight
what's the point of it you know what am
i a dude by the way did you watch the
all NBA all-star game fourth quarter
this year I'm assuming you did I don't
think I did because I generally don't
watch the all-star game because they're
kind of just like it's not real basket
can you make me one promise can you make
me one promise I'll look it up did you
I'm gonna send you two video I just want
you to watch the fourth quarter let me
let me tell you my you know how I am
with sports and when you and I talk the
opinions about sports Robert it's the
greatest quarter I've ever seen in the
history of sports when it comes down to
defense I've never seen better defense
played really never in my the new format
I can't wait for 2021 all-star game it
was that incredible no joke it was that
incredible I'll send it to you for you
to watch ok I want a dog fight I want to
fight and it's unfortunately it's not
gonna be a fight on this one this one's
gonna be it's gonna be it's gonna be a
boring matchup one day go at it I mean
so yeah I don't think Biden is at all
intimidating to him at all whatsoever I
think he's waking up saying I'm looking
forward to going up against him I think
say no I doubted more than by I don't
agree with you I agree the Bernie
probably would be a strong stronger
candidate than people think but I
definitely believe Biden his team I mean
Trump and his team are worried about by
cutting into the white working-class of
ode that is his strength because Trump
has a bedrock of support forty to forty
four percent whatever it is maybe forty
five at the most you can't win an
election on that you can sneak by with
an electoral college victory if all of
the dominoes followed precisely into
place you cut away one of his bases and
he's doomed one of his bases is the
white working-class that doesn't want a
socialist as president right they didn't
want Elizabeth Warren they don't want
Bernie Sanders he
to that because he's popular he has
appealed to a lot of workers working
class in places like Michigan
Pennsylvania even Wisconsin they were
deadly afraid of it they're playing the
numbers game they're not stupid they
understand that Trump barely he lost the
popular vote
he barely won the electoral college and
if anything Falls wrong and those three
or four key states he's in trouble and
Biden is a threat for that you think
mine's a threat for that you think that
so let me ask you right now what's your
split like saying 55% by twins you know
45% Biden where's your split right now
the weights go it's certainly over 50% I
certainly think he can win this is this
is shaping up to be a year for the
Democrats and believe me I'm not upset
about that because you know where my
politics lie but if ever there's been a
year shaping up for the Democrats to
sweep the the trifecta because they'll
keep the house they could very well win
the Senate and that presidency seems
closer than ever thanks to unfortunately
thanks to the pandemic it's this year
now you never know things could change
in the moment suddenly the corona virus
disappears the economy is booming and
Trump looks like he's smelling like a
rose I don't think so you see you never
know but if I had to put my money right
now you ask me where I put all my stock
market money I would put it on the
Democrats you would put on the Democrats
I would are you are you willing to put
10 signed copies that we give away to
our audience here of mastery 33
strategies of war against my thousand
dollars okay sign copies you put 10 of
those 2 copies each 10 10 and I'll give
you a thousand bucks which means we're
going to a Laker game or something you
choose we're gonna go somewhere well I
don't want your money okay thank you -
yeah I want you I want you to have to
wear a Biden for president t-shirt I'm
sorry every day that you come into the
office for three or four weeks that's
that's what I would like are you willing
to wear a truck
you have to have a Biden bumper sticker
on your SUV this means you're gonna have
to wear a makeup American America great
again how are you are you that confident
that Biden could win I I think I had to
back out of that he killed somebody will
come after me yeah no that had advice
that had in my neighborhood could be
deadly yeah so we want you to but I will
definitely if I'm wrong you'll get those
sign books I appreciate that I
appreciate that so final thoughts here
before we wrap up final thoughts before
we wrap up and at a time like this
I know you were talking about earlier
the fact that you know people are afraid
you know things are gonna be different
economy's gonna change you know we don't
know the ramifications of what's gonna
happen the future do you also think this
is a great time you know where it's
times like this that tend to give birth
to the next Elan to the next Vanderbilt
to the next Rockefeller to the next
great innovator to the next great
entrepreneur to the next great success
story do you think based on history
you're somebody that studied history
that it tends to produce leaders during
times of crisis and times of fear and
uncertainty do you think that's also the
case we're where we are today well I
think so I agree with that in history
has shown that happens and there's an
expression in Chinese that crisis is the
same as opportunity I mean the character
is the same and you know when there's a
lot of destruction but a lot of
industries fall apart and people are
lost and they don't know there arises
the kind of entrepreneurial spirit is
able to create new values new industries
new we need it we actually new new
political paradigms believe it or not we
need just not changes in our economic
system they also need to change in our
political system which is completely
dysfunctional right now so we need these
kind of revolutions in all different
areas but it is not carved
in stone because it depends on
individuals and it depends on the
American spirit the American spirit in
the 19th century or even going back to
the 30s and 40s was always a can-do
spirit let's get things done let's make
things we've always been good at making
things that's been our strength we're
realistic for practical people and I'm
worried that in the last 4050 years
we've been losing that touch we've been
losing it and when you look at other
countries around the world if I had to
place my money on the United States or
on some country in Asia or an even on
Germany emerging from this stronger than
we are I don't know where I would put my
money where it's 100 years ago I would
say for certain on the United States I'm
a little bit concerned about the overall
mentality among younger people who need
who've been going through a lot of these
crises with the crash and oh wait
understandably and now this crash so it
depends on will we be able to recapture
that spirit where we were the absolute
geniuses at figuring out how to do
things how to make things how to create
new businesses etc or are we gonna
flounder are we gonna be people who who
were too rich because history is full of
empires that fell mm-hmm the Roman
Empire the greatest empire perhaps ever
and it fell right Renison
the English Empire completely crumbled
after World War one right so the history
is full of examples of empires that have
histories they reach a peak and they
they decline so I don't know if you were
asking me about the United States
because I believe in generally in the
world there will be something like this
but I'm a little bit concerned that we
might be in a period of decline I can't
say for certain but that's what I'm
that's the only qualification I gave to
your scenario because I believe that you
said a hundred percent it's true so so
you're saying that you feel the current
generation that's going through this
pandemic in u.s. is weaker than the
generation that went through crisis
under no I would never say that I
statement no I wouldn't say that I mean
I have a lot of empathy for Millennials
and I and I
to respect them and some of my the
people who work the hardest I know like
Ryan holiday they're Millennials etc so
I'd ever want to say that and something
that's been brewing well before the
Millennials it's not them it had started
in the 1960s perhaps it started in the
1950s a decline that people have written
about who are smarter than I am about
what's going on with our education
system with our university assistant
with how we're training and educating
people in this country about the whole
kind of entrepreneurial spirit that used
to be so important to us it's not just
Millennials it's something that goes
back further has to do with their
parents in the parent and their
grandparents etc so if there's a decline
it's not just one generation that's to
blame it's it's all of us that are to
blame something going on in a cycle that
naturally happens when you get fat and
contented and successful you generally
take your foot off the pedal you
generally become kind of complacent and
I've been in countries I traveled to
Russia
I was recently in the Ukraine for a talk
I've been in Asia India these are places
where I see a lot more kind of energy
and desperation to succeed in life
I see more you know and I'm a little bit
concerned about that I see what you're
saying
so the word you use in his desperation
leads to people having their backs
against the wall to go out there and
whatever okay no and that's a different
story and by the way it's I think it's
fair to say that this next generation
has it's on them to prove that there is
strong generation it's not on anybody
else it's on them to go out there and do
their part and kind of prove that hate
it is gonna produce some strong leaders
and I'm kind of curious myself because
you know there's also this element of as
you age you always think you had it
harder than the current generation and
you know these guys are not as tough as
we used to be and we used to be stronger
than all this other stuff and I think
each generation maybe you disagree with
me or tends to kind of hear that from
their parents and their grandparents and
it kind of pisses them off where they
say you know what screw you go prove you
wrong exactly exactly and I hope they
are gonna get pissed up and prove me
wrong you know because because you know
our survival depends
on the spirit and energy of young people
it's not old farts like myself who are
gonna remake this world it's people who
are in their 20s we're gonna make or the
dynamic force they create new train
trends they create new fashions they
create new businesses they're the ones
with the energy and the creative spirit
to make it happen so I hope to god that
this generation why that is coming up
right now is what we call because I
wrote about this in my last book I had a
chapter on generations
I hope they represent what I called the
revolutionary generation they are gonna
remake the world I'm not saying that
they won't I just have my concerns
that's all
I think that's fair and by the way to
the generation he's talking about you
may want to go read this book okay
mastery if you've not read this you may
want to go read this book and to the
generation that's maybe a little older
maybe like 40 50 s you may want to read
the laws of human nature because that'll
give you an idea of how to work with
Millennials because this gives you a
complete perspective on on people so
having said you work with a lot of
Millennials I suppose are you are you
somewhat pessimistic based on that or
not no I think you know my wiring is
because you got to realize my life I was
born or raised in Iran I saw war happen
bombs people dying killing you know
people were afraid to go to work the
next day build businesses they were
bullied to have businesses being taken
away I lived at a refugee camp so I've
seen so much [ __ ] that to me this has
nothing compared to what we went through
in Iran and it doesn't mean it's great
I'm undermining what's happening at all
the hundred thousand lives listen one
life is someone's pain that they have to
go through I'm just saying you know with
500,000 people in Iran with the war and
an ugly way when it was going it's very
very painful when your business blows up
you know it's a difference between it
goes out of business versus it blows up
so I've come from a place of thinking
mankind as general mankind is capable of
doing a lot of big things for themselves
and just like the Marines just like the
seals just like the Rangers when crisis
happens the leaders are instructed to
have faith and strong sense of
confidence that we can pull this off and
because that breeds confidence in their
peers as they're going through it I
think this is also
for us to be paranoid I do believe we
need to be paranoid because it's night
not to be but I also think it's good to
be optimistic and kind of go out there
and prove the world no you got the juice
to make a difference and at the end of
the day someone's gonna be right
someone's gonna be wrong and someone's
gonna be right and make take us a few
years to find out who's right
yeah but I'm usually the one who's right
well that's the part with human this is
why have you wondered why have you
disturbed because that's a joke yeah the
one thing I would say though is in these
times that are very difficult in trying
for all of us you have to see it as a
tremendous personal opportunity this is
an opportunity for you to look at your
own flaws your own weaknesses to see how
you're maybe not so little not so
patient to read more books to think
about yourself to think about your
future more this is a time you can use
to toughen yourself up which is very
important so you disappeared on me again
okay
so that's what you were saying this is a
great time to toughen yourself read more
for that more about yourself again
yeah that's all I agree and this is why
you're here to enlighten us Robert you
know this is why you're here to give us
a couple different perspectives on life
today because we needed to hear from you
all right all right that's always nice
to hear Thank You Patrick thank you so
much for the opportunity you know your
experience is so interesting you you
there's a great book waiting to come out
yes I mean I'm excited about it I'm
excited about your next five moves no no
no you're but you need you have a book
about your life experience oh okay
that's not out yet
yeah your story would be very inspiring
to a lot of people I think my story's
still got some work to do I I still have
a couple other things I'm trying to add
to it but you know our relationship got
started very interesting when we were in
Glendale and the first time you and I
went to rock this place and I realized
you love Rafi's and the owner of Rafi's
is a die-hard fan of your book and then
from there led to us doing our first
interview like eight nine years ago
whatever the timeline
to be where it's at today but I'm very
glad we formed a relationship friendship
to where we are today and I cannot wait
truly I cannot wait for the next time we
go to game together with the cameras up
we can shoot the [ __ ] and talk [ __ ] to
each other for three four or five hours
yeah yeah me too that's kind of